let's spin the wheel here we go
i love spinning this wheel so much all
right here we go x
oh yes it's the letter d robin d
how much money were you having
maybe don't help fred but robin will win
if you uh
blurt out answers like that i'll win
nothing here we go
here is your clue you got that right
i'll give it to you have again
of course i have this my favorite whack
packer of all time
yes derrick from texas d
is for derek from texas of course we
know the late great whack packer eric
the actor at one point said he would no
longer call into our show
that's right from the show again
and he couldn't take it it had been days
had gone by
and he called in as derek the
actor from texas there is a guy named
derek who's been calling
claiming he's not eric the actor you
decide how's that
hello sir yeah i'm here
claim your name is derrick and you're
not eric the actor
you got that right hmm he does have
where do you live
derek texas has anyone ever told you you
sound like eric the actor not
really wow
amazing can you believe derek made the
list after only calling it once isn't
that amazing that
that's an incredible ability to do one
phone call and wind up in howard stern a
to z
yes you know it's amazing fred at the
time i said to you fred
this guy derek sounds like eric i think
it is actually eric the actor and fred
goes no no no i don't believe it is i
believe
he fooled you he fooled you i still
don't think he's the same guy but there
you go you're calling [ __ ] on all
right why was he angry what was the
reason he was so pissed off that he
wouldn't call on the show does anybody
remember because i don't
it could be any number of reasons it
could it could have been that howard
didn't pick up his call
it could be that howard wasn't playing
his shitty american idol podcast enough
it could be anything
i usually i think it was that i wasn't
helping him get work right a lot of
times it was that
like uh but why wasn't i taking his
calls why wasn't i promoting him
it could have been that we didn't get
him his wwe tickets on time it could
have been anything right
it could have been anything the derrick
thing was so great that i i said uh gee
you're a man of one voice
your talents are incredible do you think
wrestling is fake like eric the actor
does
well lots of texans like
wrestling yeah but eric the actor thinks
all those guys are [ __ ] do you agree
with that
from the history that i no i don't
believe that's
true